[Music]
i have an update on kimye's whereabouts
apparently he was spotted in downtown
los angeles the police have him cornered
they're about to take him home back to
his parents let's go live to the scene
and see what's going on
there's the police
there's the baby
and he's about to give himself up no
he's riding a dog
he's getting away
he's headed he's he's making a run for
it now
oh
that is awkward okay the police are
looking they can't find him no one knows
oh there he is
kimmy hiding out in a manhole cover now
kimmy is on a skateboard
heading away from the police once again
he's getting away thank you gopro looks
like he's making a go for it and he's
headed towards a blimp and now getting
away
kimyan's escaping on a plane
unbelievable
[Music]
[Applause]
unbelievable
what's that
what's that the producer's pretending to
tell me something what doing what
acted out some more he's doing what
come on really act it out
act it out more
he's coming this way oh
did you hear that he's headed this way
he's got little goggles
and now headed out of the studio goodbye
kim yay goodbye
stupidest thing i've ever seen
i gotta say though what a brave kid
think about it sure he may not have
loved being kim and kanye's baby but
that is incredible he's willing to give
up hundreds of millions of dollars and a
life of absolute luxury
[Music]
me
[Applause]
that was a happy ending yeah
it's like an episode of entourage
everything worked out